et la campagne de vaccination en france
se fera en trois temps d'abord les plus
vulnérables les personnes âgées en
centre de soins entre janvier et février
ensuite 14 millions de français ayant
des facteurs de risque connus et
finalement une campagne plus générale au
printemps
c'est une arme supplémentaire à notre
disposition qui va nous permettre de
mieux nous protéger
la france a commandé conjointement avec
l'union européenne auprès de six
fabricants différents le feu vert pour
la mise en marché du premier de ces
vaccins celui de fire devrait être donné
d'ici au 29 décembre prochain par l'
agence du médicament de l'union
européenne promet le premier ministre
des répétitions en allemagne et en
belgique sont en cours pour surmonter
les défis logistiques de sa distribution
sur tout le territoire européen
le vaccin doit être transporté à -80 de
grille pour conserver son efficacité la
france disposera ainsi d'un potentiel de
200 millions de doses ce qui permettrait
de vacciner 100 millions de personnes
puisque le vaccin nécessite à ce jour
deux injections à quelques semaines
d'intervalle se faire vacciner restera
entièrement volontaire est venu préciser
le ministre de la santé oliveira le
premier principe c'est le libre choix
des patients le président la république
a été très clair personne ne sera obligé
de se faire vacciner
le deuxième principe celle avec la
gratuité du vaccin parce qu'il ne faut
pas qu'ils les barrières financières
évidemment pour l'accès à la vaccination
est le troisième principe qui pourrait
être aussi le premier c'est la sécurité
il reste beaucoup de travail à faire
pour convaincre les français de se faire
immuniser si l'on en croit une étude
récente
près d'un français sur deux ne veut pas
ou très peu être vaccinés contre la
copie de 19
la méfiance est importante je sais et
j'entends les réticences voire parfois
les craintes exprimées par certains
d'entre vous les vaccins pourtant une
chance qu'il faut saisir croit le
ministre de la santé
la peur du vaccin n'arrêtera pas le
virus ni celui ci ni les autres mais le
vaccin non plus enfin pas complètement
rappelle-t-il
à ce stade on ne sait pas encore
garantie
ir 4 vacciner et protège les autres on
sait que ça se protège comme on se
protège toi même les gestes barrières
seront encore nécessaires pour longtemps
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris